All right. Um, welcome to the DDPS
seminar everyone. Before we introduce
our invited speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of all,
please mute yourself during the talk.
But if you have questions, you can
unmute and ask questions or use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in Q&A session at the
end. Second, today's DDPS seminar is
open to external audience. Uh,
therefore, no classified discussion is
allowed. So please watch out. Finally,
the talk today will be recorded and
uploaded in our YouTube channel. Um
that's about it. Now let me briefly
introduce our speaker today. It is an
honor to host Raphael Pastori who is an
assistant professor in Georgia Tech. He
earned his PhD in applied mathematics
and master's degree in statistics from
Harvard University in 2020. Prior to
Georgia Tech, he was a post-doal
associate at MIT mathematics where he
worked closely with the MIT IBM Watson
AI lab. Raphael's research focuses on
scientific machine learning at the
intersection of applied mathematics and
machine learning and inverse design uh
via scientific uh machine learning and
large scale electromagnetic design.
Today Rafael will talk about input space
scientific uh machine learning for PTE
constrained optimization of geometries
which sounds pretty interesting. So I'm
sure we are going to hear a wonderful
talk. Now let me ask a a questions uh
Rafael if it is okay somewhat informal
questions.
>> Sure.
>> Uh to get to know you better and uh make
this seminar somewhat informal. uh um if
you can share like how you got into this
field and what motivated you and you
know what makes you the most excited
about the work you are doing right now
if you can share some some personal
story that would be awesome.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh actually I I I tackled
that in my next slide so if I can start.
>> Oh you do? Okay. Yeah just go ahead.
Yes. Perfect.
>> So hi. Thank you. Hungsu for the
invitation. Um I really appreciate it.
Um the title is a mouthful but I'm going
to speak about uh input space scientific
machine learning for PD constraint
optimization and I will focus on
geometries. Um and so I I'm I'm going to
I'm going to explain a little more how I
got into this by uh uh uh
repeating uh uh parts of my resume uh
but but also explaining like what
happened during those lines. And so uh I
started my PhD in 2014 uh in applied
mathematics and I focused I was uh
originally a physics student. So I came
in as a physics student and um I was uh
really interested in uh this uh optical
devices called optical metaurfaces. So I
did my my uh uh uh training in France
where there was a lot of mathematics and
physics and I had just an interest in
devices and and and uh and and and uh um
and and design. And so when I when I
when I joined I joined as a actually as
a physics student and not an applied
math student. And um I was I was I was
noticing that uh in the lab I joined for
those optical method surfaces there were
still a lot of uh uristic based
optimization. And I was wondering like
why are we not using the math like
Maxwell's equation or linear equations
should not be like impossible to
leverage for like PD constraint
optimization with a more like
mathematical approach and then I
realized that like actually it was a
difficult problem because it was a there
was a a computational bottleneck. It was
a difficult simulation problem before
even being able to optimize it. And so I
switched to applied math. uh then I
reapplied and uh switched to the apply
math apply math program and focused on
like uh creating uh scalable approximate
solver uh for uh optical meta surfaces.
Uh and then um I continued uh doing that
in in my posto at MIT. Um but uh in in
fact in my uh scalable approxim
approximate solver one of the uh key
component was to replace uh it was
basically a de composition methods that
would break the design domain in uh uh
many many small subdomain simulation and
the key accelerating component was to uh
train a datadriven model of the
subdomain simulations. uh so it could uh
it was it was a a fitting a good
datadriven problem and that's kind of
how I got into surrogate models. So at
first my first surrogate models were um
I don't know if I talk about this today
but uh were polomials so they were not
really they were datadriven but they
were not really machine learning they
were just traditional by math um and
then I was like I I hit the curse of
dimensionality and that's how I got into
scientific machine learning and tried to
do uh data efficiency and that was uh
that was the the what I got uh that was
most of my research in scientific
machine learning in during my my postoc
and Since then, so I I started with
solvers, then I was like, "Oh, I can
accelerate with machine learning." And
since then, since I started my my
faculty position, well, I continue
trying to accelerate PD solutions, but I
I also value um the fact that uh we have
great solvers for PTE uh and that like
they they have the the the nice property
especially for Maxwell's equation, but
also others that like they certify the
physics, right? we know that like the
output is physical and and and and
generalization is really something I've
been struggling with in in uh in my uh
uh uh scientific machine learning
research. So I was like oh how can I uh
how can I uh uh leverage this uh uh this
scientific machine learning while still
using uh PD solvers uh that that are uh
certified. And so that's how I got into
uh MLN PD constraint optimization that
I'm going to talk about in the second
part of my talk today. Uh I also uh in
my in my group have a research interest
in uh end toend optimization and code
design. So where you're trying to
optimize a physical device that uh needs
to obey partial differential equations
but also end to end with uh uh software
postprocessing from the data you gather
from that device. uh and also have an
interest in a more u uh uh uh uh
scientific machine learning problem
which is how to bridge uh theorydriven
and and datadriven models and that's
more for like model discovery and and
and and modeling in general for very
complex systems. Um I'm going to talk
about the ML and NPD constraint
optimization today. And one last point I
wanted to make was that like I I am
doing a tenure track and so um it means
that I will have a tenure case coming up
in 2028. So if you receive an invitation
to review my case, please send back
something. You can say like I don't like
what Rafael does, but like send back
something.
That's that's very important for the
dinner case. Uh anyways, so just to uh
thank you for that question. I really
appreciate it. Uh so uh um I want to
frame a little bit like what I'm what uh
what I want to talk about today. The
idea is like we want to to discover a
geometry. So we geometry by geometry I
mean like the distribution of materials
that will constitute a device later that
you can fabricate through maybe additive
man manufacturing 3D printing or even
lithography depending on the
application. Um and so you're in that
situation where you have a
parameterization of a geometry this
vector P and you want to find the
geometry the vector P that will maximize
a function of physical fields. So we
want to find a geometry that that's
optimized that uh that PTE solution
here. This this f uh I will limit it to
scalar functions because we care about
like maximizing one property.
Of course the physical fields are
highdimensional and so the impact of
that kind of research is to produce a a
physical and fabricable design that
would solve an engineering problem. Um
and just like quickly uh for uh uh the
uh people who think that like maybe like
considering any scalar functions uh uh
might be limiting um uh you can have
like multiple goals uh uh that you need
to take into account in your
optimization. Uh but by setting it uh as
a a scalar optimization uh you you can
still do that. uh you just need to check
to to to pick what is the goal you
really want to maximize and and
understand what are the goals that are
more um you know uh uh uh constraints
like criteria criteria that you need to
meet and those can be uh enforced as
nonlinear constraints to your design. So
here I kept like a it's still a fairly
general uh uh uh problem formulation.
These are u a few uh devices that I uh
uh uh have worked with or I am currently
work working with uh uh to just to try
to uh give a a little more substance to
those geometries that I'm talking about.
So this is a an example of optical
metaurface. It's a really nice uh art
rendering of of a meta metaurface. It's
basically uh uh using um scattering
properties of light to shape uh
transmitted or reflected lights from
those uh uh uh nanoructures.
Um and they they they uh they've been
around for more than a decade now. um
and and they're very compact in contrast
to um uh you know usual u traditional uh
uh um optical devices which rely more on
propagative properties of light and so
they are usually thicker. Um I've worked
also on thermal design here to imagine
like that's that's basically a a
material you're trying to to optimize uh
its uh uh uh heat flux at some points
and what you can do is like punch holes
uh at different places uh and and you
want to know like where do you punch
holes in order to to get to your to your
heat flux. So some thermal design. I am
currently working on mechanical uh
design and and mechanical metamaterials.
And fairly recently I also had a a a
chemistry application where uh we were
still optimizing um
an optical uh um an optical device uh
this this meta surface again. But the
goal here was chemistry. So it was a
nice end to end optimization of uh of of
optics and chemistry. Okay. And so uh um
I my my my talk is about input space uh
machine learning uh uh uh and so I
wanted to also define what I mean by
input space. So the the the
you know I'm going to talk al so the the
the input space by what I mean uh with
in input space is that we're trying to
do some uh uh uh uh representation or
machine learning of the input to a PD
solver. So how you know uh uh uh how to
represent the geometry and usually the
geometry then when you put in the ge PD
server it will it will uh impact the PD
solver in its co in the coefficient of
the PTE and so we we learn a
representation
uh uh of the of the input and this is in
contrast to uh out output space machine
learning where we learn a representation
of the solution and so here the goal is
more to accelerate PD solver. So usually
when we do up output space machine
learning we're trying to replace that PD
solver
u and uh and the good thing with the
output space machine learning which is
not what I'm going to do today uh um is
that like it applies to many things you
can do PD constraint optimization but
you can also do decision making control
and uncertainty quantification using a
similar model so like you have like a
lot of usability from it has had some
success in the past with alpha food and
things like that. But but to me there
are there are a few drawbacks uh uh um
and and it's it's definitely not an
obsolete field. It's it's a very
thriving field. But I'm going to talk
about input uh space machine learning
today because of those drawbacks is that
often we're trying to rediscover some
known physics through data. So you know
like if we already know the physics why
do we need to rediscover rediscover it?
I already mentioned it. um there's this
this lack of generalizability and if we
use a solver for optimization and it's
not generalizable and the the design we
end up uh having with this model uh is
where the model is is not physical then
we end up with a non-physical design and
and that's not very useful and and so
and that's also related like the those
type of models they're hard to certify
uh or even to verify uh uh uh when
you're using them to make sure that like
they're they're giving you a a
meaningful result. So input space
machine learning is what I'm going to
talk about today. We're trying to learn
a representation of the input of a PD
solver. And so this is uh uh more likely
to work uh to to have a to have impact
on PD constraint uh design. At least
that's the focus I've had. I haven't
extended it to decision making control
or UKQ. Um and part of the reason is
that we still have this this idea of
input space uh machine learning is that
like at least at optimization time you
still have a solver in the loop. We
still have a PD solver that you need to
query. Uh so the benefit is that uh you
need to you you you have your physics
that is certified because you delegated
your physics to uh a solver that is
transparent. Um and uh the question here
is like well how can we leverage this uh
machine learning? How can we create a
representation learn a representation
that would shorten the lead time to
discovery?
And so in that context the baseline
really is uh um uh uh the is going to be
the state-of-the-art in optimization
rather the state of the rather than the
state-of-the-art art and output space
machine learning. So I'm going to talk
about uh the state-of-the-art
optimization as a baseline today. I'm
going to uh reduce the scope of my
method to um uh two cases. Um uh one
when uh you have a computational
bottleneck. So uh solving for these
fields is expensive. It hurts. So you
don't want to do it like thousands of
times. Uh but you can still do it
probably 1,000 times. So, if you can
just do it three times, I don't think
the method I'm going to show the method
I'm going to show today is going to
work. But if you can still do it like
hundreds uh or a thousand time uh uh
then then that that's the that's the
sweet spot of what I'm going to talk
about today.
Um the second the second uh scope uh uh
is that like uh I'm talking about cases
where f is is is uh is nasty in a sense
that like it's non-convex. Uh it might
have a a landscape that has a lot of
local optima. Uh why? It's because like
I'm going to compare myself against
baselines that are gradient based
optimization
um or uh or the state-of-the-art of
optimization. And then for convex uh
functions uh or for uh uh um well
behaved uh functions um uh then you
might not need to improve the
state-of-the-art and you might be
already good with what already exists.
So that's why I added that that that
scope qualifi qualification. And um and
then the last thing is that like the the
the parameterization of the space this
geometry that you're trying to define um
it's non-trivial to parallelize uh to
parameterize and uh it could be
represented like in a naive way with uh
a very highdimensional
uh physible space like thousands to
millions to um I'm not going to show it
today but I have even a design that has
a billion parameters and So, and so um
for that reason um the the baseline I'm
going to uh uh compare against really is
gradient based optimization because
other methods uh won't scale uh with the
the this size of input. Uh so so what we
want to compare against uh is gradient
based optimization which which scales
because uh even for PTE actually that's
my next point. um we have efficient ways
to compute uh uh the the gradients uh uh
regardless of the number of parameters
and that's solving
a a related problem which is the the
adjoin simulation and for you all I give
a just a refresher and maybe an insight
on what the adjint method is. Um this is
this is uh actually uh the the idea to
understand is is quite simple. So I like
to to I teach that that those slides but
I I I I think it's it's nice to to go
over it real quickly. So here and I
apologize I I changed the notation
already but here we try to optimize this
uh p uh that is the parameterization of
the geometry uh we try to find the the
the parameterization p to maximize the
the the objective function g of x and p.
uh and so x are uh solutions to the pd
fields and uh in what I told you before
really p will affect uh g only through x
so it would be really like g in
parenthesis a g of x of p well but what
what I what in what I've presented just
before and so as I said like uh your
your uh x is a solution to a pde here
just for simplicity I present the
reasoning for uh linear PTE and like
where you already have uh uh discretized
your PD and and that's how you would
solve a linear system I I show uh just
after uh that that you you can relax
that to nonlinear problems so you can
compute that efficiently gradients to
nonlinear problem as well and so now you
want to get the gradients of uh your
objective with respect to uh your
parameters and so for this you you just
have a chain rule and in that chain
chain rule. The the problematic term is
this one. G the derivative of the
partial derivative with respect to x
times the partial derivative of x with
respect to p. Uh with a little bit of
matrix uh uh calculus uh we can find
that like the the the derivative of the
the field with respect to one of the
pixel one of the parameters pi would
look like this. And so this term becomes
this one here at the bottom. And if you
look at it a little bit, if we
parenthesize it that way, what it looks
like is P solves. So we we're solving P
is the dimension of the of the vector P.
We need to do P simulations.
Uh A minus one times like and and we
have this this right hand term. So
that's not very efficient because if I
have a billion parameters in P now I
need to do a billion simulations just to
get the great one single gradient. But
the magic of the adjint method is just
that we re reparize
this this this uh uh this term here into
uh the into the the right hand drum of
uh the right hand side of this equation.
And what we see now is that when we re
reparize this what we we what we
discover is that like oh we could do it
as like solving a single simulation. Now
it's not exactly the same simulation and
then we just need to multiply by a
matrix. So that's that's where there's
no magic in the uh method. It's just uh
the chain rule and reparenthesizing.
And so from this uh uh uh uh from this
term we we derive the adjint simulation
the adjint simulation which is such and
that's where we see actually why it's
called the adjint simulation because the
adjint simulation is basically the same
linear simulation but instead of taking
the PD operator we take here it's it's
transpose but if it was complex it would
be its adjint
and then uh we obtain that way once we
compute our single adjint simulation we
we we obtain that way very efficiently
the gradient that we care about.
Um so that's uh I'm not entirely sure
why it's repeated but that's that's
that's the gist of it and and and really
because the the derivative operator is a
linear operator. This extends to uh
nonlinear uh PDEs. Uh this will still
the adjint simulation will still be a
linear solve and that comes really from
the fact that the the derivative
operator is a linear operator. So well
so gradient based optimization is nice.
It has this this uh efficient
computation of the gradient. So that's
why it scales um and it's a an efficient
way to get to a local optimum.
But um and so that's why as I said out
of scope of this project uh are uh
methods that that are non-gradient based
because uh they would converge too
slowly. At least that's the assumption I
make here. Um and so what is the what is
wrong with the state-of-the-art then? So
there are a couple things that I think
are problematic with this this
state-of-the-art um for PD constraint
optimization of functions that are very
non-convexed. Um and uh the the major
problem I have with it is that it's
essentially me memoryless. What do I
mean by that? I mean that when you
when you have done an optimization run.
So within optimization run, you might
you might use uh uh uh uh information
across uh iterations. But once you're
done and you've you've arrived to a
local optimum and you're not happy with
that local optimum, which happens uh
often for very non-convex functions,
then you need to start from scratch with
another initial guess. And you can
really use the information of all those
PTE solves that you've done for your
first optimization run. Uh and as a
reminder, each optimization steps uh
they can be costly because they require
at least two PD simulations. The the
forward simulation to evaluate the cost
function and the adjint simulation to
evaluate the gradient. And so the
today's agenda is to uh look at input
space machine learning uh for two goals.
one is to accelerate the simulation uh
via surrogate models and the second is
via enhancing exploration of the
physible space. So on accelerating
simulation via uh surrogate models, it's
usually what I would call output space
machine learning but I have an and and
there is a lot of work in that space on
physics informed neural networks which
basically gives you a solver that is
datadriven not necessarily the fastest
but it has the benefit of solving an
inverse problem as fast as the forward
sol uh problem. So it can be useful
sometimes in th in those settings. Um
you have operator learning and there are
like end-toend methods uh uh that can
that can uh use this this this uh uh
surrogate models of the output space.
I'm going to focus on this uh physics
enhance deep surrogate because even
though there are some models that that
try to just accelerate the prediction of
the function it is somehow some input
space machine learning and so I wanted
to to al to to start with that. So what
is a surrogate model? Um well if I I'm
going to use an illustrative example
with optics here. So I if I if I wanted
to get the transmission through that
structure. This is a 2D structure that
is repeated at infinity left and right
and you have incoming light coming from
the bottom and you're trying to compute
the complex transmission at the top. Um
well uh what you could do is just uh
have that computational domain with
peric boundary condition solve maxwell's
equation here held equation and then
from the fields you computed uh you get
the transmission coefficient the idea of
a surrogate model and here I want to
clarify what I mean by surrogate model
because it's it's not uh necessarily the
same as uh uh in the literature for me a
sur a surrogate model is a datadriven of
a scalar property of a solution to a
PTE. So it's just it's just trying to
predict a property. Here just the
complex transmission from a
parameterization of the problem. Here
the parameterization
it becomes the input of that surrogate
model. Here the parameterization has
like 10 geometrical parameters. It's the
width of those squares and uh one
physical parameter which is the
frequency of the incoming light. And so
the the the circuit model what does it
do? it it it basically evaluates
uh uh uh the a datadriven model that
will give you directly the the the
complex transmission without having to
go through the step of computing the PTE
solution. And so because it it skips
that PD solution part, it's much much
faster than using a solver. So it
accelerates inverse design. Verse design
is another word for PD constraint
optimization. And
uh that doesn't tell the whole story
because there's no free lunch. It's very
fast at evaluation time. But uh you need
to in order for your model data driven
model to be good, you need to train it.
And so training requires to actually
simulate the fields many many time for
many many instances of geometries and
and frequency of uh input. Um and then
you try to optimize the global error uh
of uh your surrogate model in a
datadriven way. Why the global error?
Well, because it has to be accurate
everywhere in the physible space because
if your optimization converges on a
point where your uh surrogate model is
non-physical, then your design is
garbage. As I already mentioned, that's
the problem of generalizability.
And so a good goal for accuracy is to
reach fabrication error uh or be do
domin dominated by it because then it's
no longer your model error that is that
is dominating there's no free lunch if
we reuse it enough times then a
surrogate model might be useful but so I
I I wanted to to I did an MBA before
before starting a PhD which is pretty
uncommon. something that I liked uh and
learned from my MBA is that um you know
we put very clearly cost comparisons and
uh uh and so that's what I tried to make
because you know in scientific machine
learning less now but at some point I
thought it was it was useful to just uh
be as clear as that um we want to have a
method that cost less than the
state-of-the-art so the state-of-the-art
would be to use a solver call it uh r
time that's the number of iteration on
our gradient based optim optimization
and then we get to our design. Uh the
cost of the surrogate model is of course
like we would need to call a surrogate
model our time as well but we need to
add the cost of training that surrogate
model otherwise we uh introduced a
method that is good that is more uh
expensive than the state-of-the-art and
we want to reduce costs and so just uh
just uh writing this very clearly we can
already motivate what is the what are
the res research question for datadriven
surrogate model uh We want this we want
to satisfy this inequality. So we want
uh here are our research questions. uh
we want to be able to minimize training
data because here the cost of training
is dominated by generating the data
which is solving the the PTE many many
times and and computing the the the
property and and also we want to
accelerate evaluation so that like we
really gain at evaluation time compared
to so uh solving the the the solution as
I said before a good datadriven model uh
doesn't necessarily require uh uh neural
networks or machine learning in general
eneral uh chibichef polomials are
actually very good for a smooth
function. They're exponentially
convergent but they require the right
choice of training points u uh so and
we'll see really briefly today that the
choice of points matters um also in
machine learning but here you can see
like for the about the same number of
points using the same polomials if you
use linearly spaced points instead of
chbbyef points then chbbyf polinomials
do very poorly right you can see this
stronger phenomenon where like it's
really bad towards the end of the
interval and and that is catastrophic
for your go global error right because
if you end up with a design uh that is
in that region uh your design is very
non-physical and it tells you it I like
the the example of polinomials because
it tells us a lot um it it also
introduces the curse of dimensionality
uh the number of training data we need
uh uh of uh uh for for our polomials uh
is a power of the number uh of the
dimension of the input and so that
doesn't scale very well and so the idea
is like okay well we if we cannot do a
chiff interpolation
and we still want more parameters which
we do because there's another key
concept from optimization which is the
blessing of dimensionality which means
that when we have more degrees of
freedom we tend to do better uh how can
we uh get more degrees of freedom and
the idea is that well maybe neural
networks can help because they tend to
alleviate uh they tend to alleviate the
curs of dimensionality without solving
it completely but alleviate it maybe
better than polomials and so it's a
problem of accuracy versus training cost
now I'm putting pictures of Andre Mar
and Jim clerks Maxwell why and they
don't look happy as you can see uh why
well they they worked really hard to to
find for example the equations of lights
Maxwell's equation. Um, and now we're
talking about uh rediscovering
uh their their their work through data.
It seems a bit wasteful. And so the idea
of the physics enhance deep surrogate
that I'm going to introduce next is to
put the PTE back inside the the blackbox
model. So uh physics enhance deep
surrogate was published a couple years
ago in nature machine intelligence.
And so the idea is like we have a
parameterization of the geometry. Here
is just a card of the geometry. Really
the in the results is going to be this
uh this illustrative example I presented
earlier with 10 parameters in the
geometry. We have an accurate Maxwell
solver. Uh thanks to it we compute the
transmission and we're trying to
reproduce that data. The link between
geometry and complex transmission.
the uh the machine learning baseline
that we use is to just have uh the same
parameterization as as input and train
to uh um predict the complex
transmission with a neural network. And
so the idea of PES is to open the black
box. The first thing we do with PES is
to put a solver back inside the the box.
So the the last layer of the of the of
the model is a solver. But how is it
like gaining us anything? Well, it's
gaining us something because it's a low
fidelity solver. So, it evaluates much
faster than the the high accuracy
solver. Uh, unfortunately, it's also
very wrong. So, if we just use our low
fidelity solver to compute the complex
transmission, we would have terrible
accuracy with errors like up to 100%.
because the in the case of Maxwell's
equation because the those those uh
those low fidelity solvers they in max
equation have resonances it's resonance
phenomena and those low fidelity solver
they usually get those resonances wrong.
So if you're if you're if you get your
resonance wrong very quickly you have
very large errors. Um so why am I uh
presenting this in an input space
machine learning uh uh presentation?
It's because the method the the key of
the method is to leave the physics to
the neural to to leave the physics to
the solver and with the neural network
just trying to find what is the input
that will make that solver accurate not
for the full solution but just for the
complex transmission for that uh uh
scalar property. And so that's the whole
idea of pets. We have this uh uh uh uh
end to end training of a uh neural
network generator uh that will discover
uh the the the geometry transformation
from the the original parameterization
to what should be the input geometry to
the solver to make it accurate for that
property that we care about. So we were
very happy with the results um in load
data regime. That's just for Maxwell's
equation. Uh uh we we could see um uh uh
three times improvement here. I want to
I just want to quickly mention that like
here we used peds and we also used an
active learning algorithm that I didn't
have time to introduce but uh uh that
just echoes the fact that like the
choice of points matter. So we really
want to compare those two methods which
are using both using active learning
this this creation of a data set that is
most informative for the for the model
we're training we see that like in low
data regime like we we're three times
better in accuracy now this is still an
accuracy that is too high for inverse
design purpose for PD constraint
optimization purpose but something we're
also very excited about this is too
little data to say anything about
asmtotics but we could reach the error,
the fabrication error levels that we
need uh to be dominated uh by by
fabrication error and no longer by model
uh error. And so we could use that model
for inverse design. We're very happy
with that. And and to show that like
this uh uh uh uh is not just for
Maxwell's equation but for other types
of PTE. This was uh illustrated on other
PTEEs as well. The diffusion equation
and the reaction diffusion equation. An
interesting thing is that the reaction
diffusion equation is a nonlinear PTE as
you can see with this nonlinear term and
the low fidelity solver was no long not
only a relaxation of the discretization
it was a coarse finite difference solver
instead of a fine enough uh resolution
but it was also a relaxation of the
physics. We did a linear relaxation of
the physics uh here using just a
diffusion equation instead of the
reaction diffusion equation for the
diffusion and reaction diffusion
equation. This is what the geometry
looked like. We had dish durishly
boundary conditions and this structure
in the in the geometry. And you can see
that diffusion and reaction diffusion
equation don't give the same solution
for the same geometry. And so the the
results here is that we could disc
decrease
the evaluation costs
uh so by you know 500 times to 10,000
times. Um and uh we could so so that's
good. That was uh going back on my
little like business like equations. Uh
we reduced the valuation time. That was
good. We also wanted to reduce the the
the data cost. uh and the data
generation cost. And what we can show is
that by multiplying the number of
training data by 100 uh the neural
network only baseline could still not
reach the the the error uh reached by
pets. So we have at least a reduction of
uh uh two orders of magnitude in in data
uh cost needed. And so uh with with such
a a method we're much more likely to
make uh um to make a surrogate model
worth it. Now I want to switch gear a
little bit though it's still input space
machine learning and I want to talk
about uh enhancing the exploration of
the feasible space. So hopefully here
this is a familiar architecture. Now I
have a a latent space uh here it was
before it was this uh parameterization
of a geometry. Then I have a
representation
and and and what should be familiar is
that it should be familiar to pens. Here
we had like the neural network
generation
uh of the input to a PT solver and here
we have our PD solver and then a
property. The difference here is that
now the PD solver is not a low fidelity
PD solver. It is just a regular PD
solver that is like certifying the
physics and so we know that we can trust
this outcome of the prop PD property but
it comes at a cost. Now we need to solve
the PTE uh every time we evaluate that
pipeline and so the goal is to get to a
good optimum by reducing as much as
possible the number of calls to the true
solver. But what we gain is that we know
for sure that the resulting design will
be physical. And so this is all
differentiable. You can uh evaluate uh
with forward evaluation. You can uh back
propagate through this. Of course, you
might need to uh determine your own
primitive for the the back propagation
rules on your PD solver by introducing
the adjoin simulation. That's going to
be more efficient.
And so
you we we we have a we we have that
system. The question is like well how do
we do input representation learning
right? We have that uh that uh uh
representation that we're now trying to
learn. We're still doing ML enhancement
of optimization. Um so we we could we
could try to have uh uh to to to to get
uh designs uh that are uh that are per
high performing and then we try to learn
a representation a good representation
of those designs and that would probably
learn the geometric features that makes
a good design. Now that's a chicken and
egg problem because if I had already
good designs for that property I would
probably not need to do an EPD uh uh uh
uh constraint optimization. So we have
that kind of problem and the method I'm
going to present next kind of solves
that problem. But having that
parameterization here gives us also many
opportunities. Um it gives us control of
uh the search space of how we explore
the physible space. We can maybe like uh
uh uh infuse some mathematical property
uh to it. For example, we could reduce
the dimension. So the input to to this
representation becomes a lowdimensional
input instead of a highdimensional
input. Uh we may leverage pre-trained
representation and just do uh transfer
learning and fine-tuning and so we need
less PD solve to have a better
parameterization.
Uh and and another thing is that like
the uh the the representation is
independent from the solver that you
use. So you might use like maybe a a
suite of solvers uh uh to get to learn
your parameterization. At least a
framework like that would be agnostic to
it. So you could use whatever you
prefer. I'm going to present in the next
uh okay six minutes. Is that okay? Yunu
is it is it okay if I have six seven
minutes left?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um so this is work that was
conducted by uh Raza Ma Mazban in the
group of professor Ali Adibi and
together we developed this uh this uh
new method. Uh and so the goal just to
show like what device we tried to do. We
had this uh uh uh there was this this
was published last year. There was this
uh uh deflector that is useful in
augmented reality where you're trying to
send light at a deflecting uh angle that
is the same for red, green and blue. And
normally you have chromatic aberration
and you don't deflect light at the same
angle. But here we really wanted to have
a design that would deflect light at the
same angle for augmented reality
applications. And the design that we
have is uh is this kind of a structure
here that is repeated in a x and y
direction with a given period uh lambda
x and lambda y uh and with different
thicknesses and of course a very uh uh
complex pattern that is going to be
repeated and we try to optimize all
those things to maximize the efficiency
of the deflection in the angle that we
care about.
And so as I said the the the first
problem we have is the chicken and egg
problem like how do we create a data set
uh to learn a representation that would
uh that that would do just what we need.
Uh and for this we use the uh uh the
state-of-the-art of topology
optimization and and a fact in topology
optimization is that that that during a
run in topology optimization two things
happen. These are uristics understanding
of what's what what what happens often
first it tries to find a topology.
Topology mathematically just means that
where do you put holes in that in that
uh uh in that geometry and then it does
shape optimization. So it changes the
shape of those poles. So what we did to
create our data set we didn't do like
full gradient based optimization runs.
We stopped them early using this early
stopping. we stopped when when we
already had like a topology but not the
the the shape optimization was not done.
So you can see here for example this is
the the uh the evolution of of our
figure of merit. We're trying to
maximize what's going on here. We can
see that where we stop at step 35. We're
not an optimum, right? Like it's
probably it could probably do better to
it's not even local optimum. Doesn't
look like it. But we stopped there
because we already have some kind of
topology that we would that that that we
would uh uh uh that we can use. Now we
with that we just created 30 goods good
good designs. So uh we did 30 * 35 uh *
two simulations to get the the the
function evaluation and and and its
gradient and we augmented the data set
because 30 good designs was was not
enough using also a uristic from
topology optimization which is erosion
and dilation. So here for example, if
you look at the white pattern in a a
black uh uh background, um if this is
the design we came up with uh uh uh at
iteration 35, we will also add this
deated version where we added a little
bit of uh uh uh uh white everywhere as
if like you know it grew. Um and also
this eroded version as if like uh in the
black area there was a lot of wind and
it eroded this white structure. So we
augmented through those uristic our data
set.
Okay. Um
and so
uh uh so this is this is uh just just uh
explaining the same the same as what I
just said. uh and and then we trained uh
our representation. The representation
is reducing uh uh the the design space
from 6,000 degrees of freedom to eight
degrees of freedom. Um and in order to
make that uh learning even more
efficient, we used the vision
transformer which was pre-trained. So in
the encoder, most of it was fixed. We
just learned the last layer uh to get a
meaningful latent space and then we also
had to train for the decoder. We trained
an autoenccoder with most of the encoder
was already transferred from a vision
transformer that was just uh trained on
images uh not really on like uh uh PD
constraint designs.
Um and then uh we could uh uh uh try to
uh uh here we we we we trained our our
latent space. We have those eight
parameters here. I'm just showing like
uh uh uh uh variations of the generated
designs when we change just one
parameters and hopefully you can see
that it really changes uh uh the
structure as we change each of the
parameters. It really captures uh
geometric features which we hope will
help us uh get to uh good designs more
quickly.
And then now we by reducing the the the
s the the physible space from from uh
6,000 dimension to just eight uh and in
fact we added even more like some
physical parameters that are technically
difficult to differentiate. They're not
non- differentiable. is just like from a
software perspective they're difficult
to to to differentiate such as um the
the period of the structure and the
thicknesses those are slightly harder to
optimize but we threw those uh uh
parameters in inside our Bayian
optimization. So we had trained we have
trained our our representation and now
we we enabled Beijian optimization
directly on that latent space and for
this every time at every step we
actually called the the certified
physics solver we didn't try to uh learn
uh the physics in a datadriven way we
just learned in a datadriven way a
representation of the physics here this
is a
uh and so the run of vision optimization
took 350 iterations. something that is
interesting. This is colorcoded with uh
the the the figure of Mary the
efficiency which is a uh this this worst
case optimization for those uh for the
deflection efficiency of those red green
and blue colors and we can see that at
first it goes uh and this is just to
analyze at posterior we did a PCA
analysis and we're just plotting those
designs uh on the first and second
components um and so we can see that at
first it's uh it's exploring designs and
then uh like Beijian optimization does
uh it it started to exploit a little bit
uh the designs and and found uh one very
good design.
Uh here
uh we also uh to compare uh although we
also had for comparison the the the the
uh the paper from uh from last year that
was using topology optimization for the
same problem. Uh but in order to compare
we also did some topology optimization
runs uh uh um actually is this oh that's
that's later okay sorry uh that that is
that is later but uh uh uh with with our
basian optimization we arrived to very
good results uh 25% efficiency for red
24% efficiency for green 24% efficiency
for blue so it's more or less equal and
it performs really well the way we would
want for comparisons with topology
optimization. We ran uh 70 runs of
topology optimization and we let it uh
we let it converge uh um more or less uh
uh on average it was doing 200
iterations for each runs. And so it took
about 14,000 uh simulations to to do all
those runs. And we can see that this
problem is a is a non-convex problem.
It's difficult. You get a lot of local
optima that are not necessarily very
good. it still got like some fairly good
results but the efficiency was not as
good as like our approach 25 22 but 19%
for blue
uh and so here again like that's where
like I want to show that well we we
really shortened the lead time to a
design we reduce the computational cost
because here uh in our case we did uh
700 simulations to get our data set and
then 350 more or less to uh to uh uh uh
do the basian optim optimization. So,
we're about at 1,000 simulations. And to
do topology optimization, we needed to
do 14,000 simulations. And in real life
topology optimization, we kind of got
lucky. We didn't do anything about
fabrication constraints and ended up
with Beijian optimization with a
fabricable design. But in topology
optimization, often you end up with
designs that are hard to fabricate. So,
you need to add this erosion and
dilation uh optimization where like you
do the worst case of those three uh uh
three designs. the design the aerody
version delayed version and so that adds
also cost like three more three times
the number of simulation. So really
saying that like we reduce by an order
of magnitude is kind of is kind of nice
for to. So we really shortened the path
and this and we could also validate that
structure. Uh we fabricated it uh and
and those uh very good design uh results
that we got for uh uh our design uh
translated
uh uh into uh fairly good results. also
uh definitely better than the former
state-of-the-art uh in in experimental
validation. We had a slight degradation
for blue. Um I think uh uh uh uh if you
look at the paper which we published on
archive um uh uh uh we we explained like
why experimentally and with respect to
fabrication uh this actually apostereia
was maybe expected but in any case we
were very happy because this is a new
state-of-the-art.
So hopefully I made a good case about
MLNP speedd constraint optimization in
particular uh how uh focusing on this
input space focusing on uh engineering a
search search space focusing on
generating the geometry. So these are
three ways of saying the same thing. Uh
really can benefit shorten the path to
discovery of designs that would be uh uh
mission critical and important and all
those designs would be certified by
physics. I have applications in my
research in mechanics, optics, uh
chemistry and thermics like thermal
property. Uh today I presented about
optics. Um I'm definitely continuing to
work in input space representation. I am
also working on uh leveraging this for
multifysics application
uh uh and and and uh uh look more into
transferring from pre-trained model and
transferring also knowledge from
multifidelity knowledge uh models. I
also have those two other uh uh
directions and please don't hesitate uh
to reach out uh if uh if uh you're
interested in any of those research uh
directions. I have my email at the end
of the presentation. I was not alone
doing this. It takes a village to do
great research. Uh George Deck, I want
to particularly thank uh Riza Mazban and
Professor Aliyah DB uh who uh who were
my uh close collaborator on that uh uh
last uh work I showed you and Reza
really did the the the firstand work. Uh
and also other collaborators.
I hope I convinced you that input space
machine learning has u good uh u uh
opportunities uh and uh and uh uh please
don't hesitate to reach out.
>> Yeah. Well, thank you. Thank you so much
for the nice talk uh Rafael.
I I'm sure many of us have enjoyed your
talk. Um let's have a Q&A sessions.
Yeah, Kami. Uh you raise your hand. Um
yeah this
>> thank you Yungu thank you Rafael very
interesting talk I really enjoy it. Uh I
have a question about pets physics
enhance deep surrogate. In one of your
slide you mentioned that pets can can
kind of open the black box of machine
learning in the context of XAI. How do
you think these pets can help us to
provide physical interpretation for
hyperparameters?
>> X AI
>> yes explainable. how can we use
>> explanable so that's that's the main
that's the main uh uh uh I mean that was
one of the motivation for having the
output of the model be uh interpretable
transparent uh we want we want the the
we wanted the output uh to be uh
computed from physical fields we have
this uh although low fidelity solver it
still solves the governing equations and
so uh the the the one of the motivation
uh that I had for for uh this type of
architecture and why for example I
didn't do any uh uh uh uh uh correction
after like you know nonlinear correction
that would add one more layer of of
neural network after that the reason why
I end with the physics is that now I can
also look into what are the what are the
solution what are the the PD uh fields
that led to this prediction. And so I
wanted to be able to and I'm working on
it uh uh do some uh uh verification and
like uncertainty quantification based on
this physical layer. There is another
physical layer which is the geometry
instead I itself. So from that
information of the geometry uh which is
interpretable and the physics which is
also interpretable and understandable uh
uh uh we're really uh including a lot of
explanation uh or explanability in the
model. Does it does it answer your
question?
>> Yes. Thank you.
>> Okay. Thank you. Uh Andre uh do you want
to unmute and ask?
>> Yeah. Hi. Can you hear me?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Thank you. Very nice talk. Uh I
really enjoyed it. I've thought about
some of these topics myself. Uh it was
very nice how you laid it out. My
question was about in the last example
that you were discussing. I think I
heard you say something to be effective.
We're not learning a surrogate for the
physics. We're learning a surrogate for
a representation of the physics. Uh can
you a little bit or just clarify that
point?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So a very important
point that like maybe I didn't make
across very well is that we leave the
physics to the solver. Like the machine
learning doesn't do anything with the
physics. What it learns is a
representation of the geometry of the
input to that solver. But the physics is
done by the solver. We're no longer
spending any simulation trying to learn
something that is already known.
>> So the surrogate is from the for
instance latent space parameterization
to the output and everything else in
between is
>> not learned.
>> So the the the it's not to the output.
So the output would be the property
right. So the the representation the the
output of our ML model is the input to
the PTE solver. So the output is not
containing any physics. is just
containing a geometry and got it
>> and that's a good thing because geometry
>> I would say that that's the non that's
the non reducible common space between
all PD constraint optimizations
uh runs right you're working at least
for geometry you're working with the
geometry if you start looking directly
at the solution then it will be PD
dependent it might be even set PD
settings dependent but the geometry
itself is more likely to have
transferable
insights from even one PD to the other.
>> Totally. I agree. Thank you.
>> Awesome. Jonas, do you want to unmute
and ask question?
>> Yes, of course. Uh Raphael, uh thank you
for that. That was really great. And I'm
surprised that Lulu has not invited you
yet to uh or maybe maybe he did invite
you, but you weren't able to make it for
a talk at um Foundation's data science.
um because there's a lot of talks of
this kind and I'm like
>> this would be very relevant work because
of the amount of people who do
electromagnet magnetics in like physics
and applied physics departments over
there at Yale but um anyways uh so um I
wanted to ask about your use of the
barial autoenccoder um for generating um
inverse design um solutions uh so
>> yeah I was curious because I So I mean
varial autoenccoder can mean a lot of
things depending on the prior you set in
the problem. Um I'm curious because you
have physical constraints have do you
consider or did you try to put those in
the prior you're using here to help
inform the solutions you're getting?
>> Do we though do we have physical
constraints since we're just trying to
create the geometry? We might have
fabrication constraints. So that
actually is a that is a project I'm
working on like how do you infuse
fabrication constraints in your
representation but we don't have
physical constraints the in a way in a
way we need to find geometry features
that are useful for our physics later so
that's only in that in that uh uh in to
that extent that we're trying to uh uh
uh uh train and to end our model but
really the output is going to be that
geometry. So, so just just to to uh uh
uh uh to to to to clarify the point,
we're working on a geometry. We're
trying to find geometrical insights and
that's not going to be as much from uh
uh you know learning the solution as to
know like just oh what are the type of
like shapes or or or uh uh latent
features that like tend to work well.
>> Got it. Got it. Sorry, I guess I was
using physical in a very general sense,
not necessarily just physics based, but
>> like what's physically possible as well.
>> So then then now I'm going to start
answering your question. Um, so how do
we learn a representation that is useful
for our PD problem, right? So to me
there are two methods to do that uh to
make sure we learn a representation that
is relevant for our PD optimization
problem. The first one is the one I'm
showing here. it would be an
unsupervised learning approach. You
don't have a data set but you're just
trying to optimize the property
directly, right? So this of course uh is
a way to learn a representation uh uh
and and you have you can create a
bottleneck or something. The problem is
that now you have a learning process
that has a PD solver in the loop and
that's not even a low low fidelity
solver in the loop. So you want to
really make it very efficient and so
that's why in that approach here we had
a data set uh approach a supervised
approach and the way we infuse some uh
uh information about what is a a
reasonably good design is uh to do this
thing this this uh it's it becomes more
a question of how do I generate a good
data set without it to cost too much
because we have this chicken and egg
problem and so here I would say one of
uh the important contribution ution of
that article and if you want to see it,
this is this art archive article. It's
currently under review. Um uh it it's
it's this data generation process here.
We actually used the state-of-the-art
topology optimization to find topologies
that were useful because we thought okay
topology will already have the
geometrical content that we t we want to
we want to use. uh we don't really care
about going all the way to a local
optimum because that's just going to
tweak those features but really we just
want to know the features and then we're
going to do our optimization on our
representation to tweak the features
afterwards.
>> Ah I see. So in other words this is
almost like initial conditions for more
refined optimization methods that
already exist.
>> It's it's one way to say is uh this is a
transfer learning approach. So instead
of like here we did 30 runs that we
stopped early of topology optimization.
Technically all those runs in the prior
uh state-of-the-art of gradient based
optimization none of those runs is
useful because like they didn't end up
with a useful geometry. And so with just
gradient based optimization we just
would have thrown all that away.
and and here instead of that we use that
to create a data to to create a data set
and learn a representation. Uh so that's
that's the that's the the yeah that's
the point I'm trying to make. Yeah.
>> I see. Okay. That makes a lot of sense
and I'm looking forward to seeing the
archive paper then. Thank you.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's yeah it's it's already
on archive. Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Awesome. Okay. Sumant do you want to
unmute yourself and ask questions?
>> Uh yeah. Uh thank you so much for the
presentation. I've been following your
work for for quite some time now. So
it's it's it's finally a pleasure to
actually like see you give the talk.
Thank you so much. So I have a couple of
questions. The first one is kind of
building on what Jonas just asked which
is on the VAE. So uh a lot of work which
have used VAE for more like physics
based approaches they don't really use
the use the like the like the
traditional way of matching the
posterior with the with the uh univer
right. So the the traditional way would
be using a kale scale divergence to do
that but some people use other forms of
loss function for example the MMD loss
function and stuff like that. So what
have what have you used or what have you
what's your experience in that? So here
we didn't put any uh any further
regularization on what the the latent
space is but of course uh I think it
would be very interesting to learn uh to
structure that latent space to get
further insight and make the the the
representation transparent as well
understanding like well what actually
drives the optimization does it does it
answer a little bit your question
>> uh can you tell me what's your prior in
this va
>> well um
here really the The optimization process
we had is like what we we used the the
vision transformer on image net and we
fixed the parameters to it.
>> Okay.
>> And then we just optimized for uh uh
just the the simplest vanilla
autoenccoder. It's not even uh or is it
varational? Yes, we probably did also
Yeah, you're right. Like we we also had
some uh uh we we uh forced a goian in
the latent space. I'm sorry we did that.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry.
>> Yeah. uh because VA comes from like
using variation inference.
>> No, no, you're right. You're right. We
did force a question in the in the in
the
>> Okay, thank you so much. And the second
question is most uh can you go back to
the slide where you show the flowchart
where you first have like you get the
output of the neural network and then
use the FD solver on that. Yeah. Yeah.
This so this is very interesting because
as you just said you use the neural
network to have an output and then you
use the PD solver on that output, right?
Right. And the neural network is trying
to achieve something as you said it's
it's a interpretable representation of
the of the of the geometry. Right. So
now uh I mean these I mean I've seen a
lot of people who have similar
approaches where they use uh the PD
solver instead of using an auto diff and
stuff like that in order to enforce the
physics right uh but when we do that uh
the traditional laws that apply to
numerical methods for example if you're
using a finite difference solver to
solve a advction equation then probably
it's not like like the rules of the
stability and everything comes into play
right? So for example, we should not use
a forward stepping the the forward time
stepper for that vection term and we
should not use this for that etc etc.
But when we use that as a surrogate for
the autodiff those rules just go away.
So we can just blindly use a central
difference method for even time and
space and stuff like that because right
now we are not really using the using
the finite difference in the traditional
numerical linear algebra kind of a way
but it's much more in optimization way.
Did you find something of similar nature
when you're trying to use that over
here? I mean, am I able to?
>> No, we we didn't we didn't I mean, it
was, you know, it's a similar to
Maxwell's equation and uh we didn't have
uh uh well, okay. Uh the only moment
where this might have happened is during
our Beijian optimization, right? because
uh uh uh during the well we we it could
have happened also during the topology
optimization but we didn't have the the
optimization run lead us to uh an input
that like uh you know the solver doesn't
converge on uh uh and then in the uh
Beijian optimization setting uh we also
did not although it doesn't matter as
much because you basically you know it's
more of a sampling based method so if
one doesn't work like you can you can
still sample others um But yeah, so does
it answer your question that like so so
I would say to to apply that to a system
where you know there are a lot of
geometries where like your solver
doesn't um uh doesn't converge uh you
know like the the so it's basically you
have a uh I would say it's in between
the software issue and and the physical
issue uh then you need to think about as
I said the good thing about this
representation learning is that it's
agnostic to the solver. So maybe you can
learn you can you can uh uh uh uh do a
progression of solvers. Maybe start the
optimization with like a solver that
maybe is not as uh accurate but that
like you know will uh converge every
time and then like as you fine-tune
maybe go towards uh a solver where like
uh you know um you know it's going to
it's going to be closer to your problem
but you know you will have also uh uh in
your batch a few cases that are not
going to run. So you need to handle your
errors. Oh, I mean so if I ask this
question, can I use a second order RK
method to solve a fourth order equation
using this?
>> So again like this is independent of the
solver. So you can read the solver that
solves whatever you want.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah, that's what
>> Okay. Well, thank you. Uh next question
is by Jan Van uh Delen. Um if you're
there um do you want to unmute yourself
and ask the question yourself
or do you want me to read your question
that's on the chat
box? I can I can read the questions.
Okay. Thanks for the great talk. In your
latent space optimization example, how
much did the size of the latent space
impact the optimization result or how
much did the number and quality of
topology optimization samples impact the
quality
>> performance? That's a that's a very good
question. This this uh this me this
article is not uh is a is a you know a
first step. It it it asks it opens more
a lot of questions. Something we we like
about that that article uh that I like
in particular is that like the proof is
in the pudding too, right? Like using
this method even though there are still
open questions on for example like how
do you use the number of uh latent
parameters or uh and things like that.
Uh we still got the new
state-of-the-art. So that was that was a
very a very uh you know uh uh impactful
validation. Uh but but uh um that is a
good question. I think I think it means
that you you got the the the
you you I I delivered the message well
because those questions are very
relevant and uh in my opinion uh uh uh I
don't have a better answer than the
current literature on autoenccoders and
choice of variables and things and
latent variables you know
>> okay sounds good uh uh next question is
by Mohammed
um he's asking in There is a Julia
package called infinite opt.julia
that lets you model design problems
where the control variables is a full
space or time dependent field. Could
your latent space plus basian
optimization workflow serve as a
practical lowdimensional surrogate for
that kind of infinite dimensional
control still allowing PD and
reliability constraints?
uh I I would say no because again the
the here the machine learning is not
learning a surrogate for the physics
right it's learning a surrogate for uh
the the geometry or the the input but uh
uh I do think right now I presented the
the within the scope of PD constraint
optimization of geometry I do think
there might be uh uh a way of uh uh
applying that to control so if you have
a geometry that evolves in time that's
that's already a control problem I do I
think there are uh uh ways to leverage
this type of thinking uh leaving the
physics to the solver uh but but uh uh
uh but still using machine learning to
um engineer the search the search space
uh I think there there are there are
probably ways to do it but I haven't
done it yet.
>> Okay. Well, there's no more questions
from the chat but I get to ask one at
least one questions
uh finally. Um well I I guess it's not a
question. It's more like a comment and
suggestions to add one more item in your
future directions. I mean it's it's nice
that you have um introduced a way of
tackling the input space in the context
of the PD constraint design
optimizations
um in various ways. Um but maybe you
want to look into how to bring the
scientific ML in PTE solver itself. And
if you just looking into traditional um
numerical method of solving PTE the
input of that um could be one of the
input could be you know that basis
representation like the polomial basis
representation which you have mentioned
in your introductory
uh slide.
>> Yeah
>> maybe we can uh change that replace that
to the datadriven basis in order to
improve the quality. That's another way
of bringing this uh scientific ML into
the numerical solver itself. Uh recently
we have published a preprint um talking
about the foundation models in
computational science and also
introduced the the framework so-called
the DDM datadriven final method. um I
can share the video and um that exactly
talks about you know that kind of input
you know it's different from uh your
input space.
>> Yeah perhaps you want to look into that.
Yeah.
>> Yes. Yes. And I'm familiar with that
work because uh uh I I I read the the
preprint. I think you read it. Okay.
>> Yes. I I I do think there is a you sent
it to me but but the it was a while back
the the so the I think there is
definitely a great opportunity here I
learn a representation of the input uh
of u of uh uh the the physical object
the device right because that's that's
but um and I'm assuming that like you
know the solver will do its job
>> but maybe sometimes you know, we we
talked about that in Q&A and I think
it's an important problem. Sometimes,
you know, you also need to make good
decisions of hyperparameters in the
solver to make sure the simulation uh
doesn't iterate forever or uh to make
sure the simulation even just converges.
>> And so
there are two ways either you could just
learn a representation to learn this uh
not just the physics parameter but also
uh numerical parameters that
hyperparameters that you need. That's
one way or you can try to also infer uh
the the these parameters from the
lowdimensional representation that you
create from of the geometry. The
rational here would be to say well if uh
those geometries are similar in a sense
of uh they have they are similar in a
similar position in the latent space
then probably the solver will need
similar hyperparameters
to uh solve this geometry efficiently.
So uh I think there there are two ways
to leverage either you use the me method
directly on numerical parameters or you
leverage the learned representation of
the geometry because in the end uh those
par those uh those uh uh implementation
of the solver will really be de
dependent on the geometry on the mesh
and things like that and so there
probably that this latent uh space uh in
and in particular if it's a compressed
latent space with low dimensionality um
uh might help uh also to to infer. So
there is definitely synergies to do
there. Yeah, I agree.
>> All right, sounds good. Well, I let's
let's end here because we already passed
like 20 minutes um past the you know the
promise time ending time.
>> Well, thank you so much for the nice
talk. Let's thank our speaker Rafael for
the nice talk and as well as a wonderful
Q&A uh sessions. Uh thank you so much
Rafael.
So with so with that, yeah, go ahead.
>> Yeah, hopefully uh if you're interested
like send me an email. Uh uh I will be
happy to to answer. I'm open for
collaborations.
>> Of course. It looks like the Sumant has
couple of more questions. So he will
email you for sure.
>> Fantastic.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So with that, let's end our
seminar today. And let me push the stop
button for the recording.